the jurgen experience did you see trump
stand in front of the church holding
that bible like it was a dirty diaper
he was like look i got the bible in my
hand take it
they thought that all went really well
they thought that was great it is
hilarious first of all they tear gas
all the [ __ ] protesters to get them
off the street you clear the street out
and then trump walks across the street
like there's never been a president so
bold to walk
they're like he's walking so he walks
across the street to this boarded down
church
it's hilarious i mean they probably had
snipers all over the room
yeah it's a dirty diaper he's holding
that thing like
like look i've got my bible [ __ ]
read me
one passage you can't mean what it asked
if it was his bible he's like
it's it's basically it's it's a bible
thank you sir i got it at a hotel i was
staying
yeah i mean what what is that why is he
holding the bible what that is the most
ill-conceived pr stunt that i've ever
seen i mean maybe yeah i actually
thought about this too because look i
mean the main reason
the main reason like trump has such a
solid hold on the
on the right like on the republican base
so to speak is because actually
of the judge's thing of the supreme
court thing which you were talking about
of selecting
mike pence who has a lot of credibility
in the evangelical community so i think
that
i mean a lot of people were outraged i
saw this this was a very like right
thing
when that you know the saint john's
church that church that you were seeing
that was set on fire right and so like
it was set on fire
and there was a lot of people like first
of all there i think it was brian
stelter over at cnn was like actually no
it's not on fire they ain't deleting
his tweet he's saying it on twitter this
guy is adorable
he's an adorable little chill he's he's
something else
but so like there there was all that and
then look there wasn't a lot of outrage
around the fact that
the church got set on fire so i get what
he was signaling to do look i agree i
told crystal this morning on the show
tear gassing the protesters and then
going out there for the photoshop on
like that i don't think it was the best
movie can you imagine being
so insecure that you're the president of
the united states like you have nuclear
arsenal
and milital american military at your
disposal
and you're so insecure that you have to
show your strength in that moment by
walking across the park and reportedly
he was upset because it had come
out that they had like had to go down
into the bunker on friday or say
a saturday night or whatever when there
were protesters and so this was his way
to reassert his
manhood but i think that's why i say i
don't think that he has like a real i
think he has instincts i don't think he
has a real
ideology i don't think he has like a
goal or a mission or a project he's
trying to accomplish
i think he's just all it i think it's
all just about like
how do i reclaim this news cycle how do
i win
the day i actually interviewed him back
before he was an official candidate at
the white house correspondents dinner i
was doing like i was like on the rope
line doing like the celebrity
interviews like sticking a mic in
people's face or whatever it was
ridiculous
but so he comes in and this is at the
time when everyone's like oh this is
just a publicity son he's not gonna run
right he comes in with melania it wasn't
the one it was maybe the one
after when barack obama made fun of him
like that and so he comes up to me and
this is when i was at
msnbc and you know i wasn't like
particularly prominent there it was one
of four
on a panel show and he locks eyes with
me and he's like
crystal oh my god it is so great to meet
you
like even then this it was like ari and
abby torre
you guys are so great together on the
cycle like he knew
the show he knew clearly he was
already obsessed with cable news and all
the
ins and outs of cable news and he was
generally like oh my god i can't believe
i get to meet crystal i'm like
how do what how do you know who i mean
it's just bizarre
but it was such a little insight into
his whole wiring
and so he knows more than anyone like
what is going to be provocative to these
stupid talking heads on cable what is
going to capture their attention
what is going to be outrageous what's
going to win the day and i don't think
that there's much beyond
that thinking of like how do i win this
news cycle how do i change the topic on
this news cycle
you